administration tries resettling illegal
aliens in say
south dakota well they're going to have
to get past governor christie gnome
first she tweeted
south dakota won't be taking any illegal
immigrants that the bide administration
wants to relocate
my message to illegal immigrants call me
when you're an american governor gnome
joins me now governor good to see you
tonight
uh now how would this work how would uh
how would you enforce this
well there's always a request you made
i would to the states where the federal
government would put the request in and
ask and what i have
determined by watching the actions of
this president is that
he is making america unsafe these are
people that are crossing our border
illegally we do not know who they are
multiple news sources have told us that
we have people on the terrorist watch
list
that are getting into this country this
way and they're not going to find a
place here in south dakota
are they legally required to alert you
to this since they say and i've heard
them say this before governor
that this is federal this is a federal
authority
the federal government is uniquely you
know charged with doing this so
you know we're going to resettle them
where we think as a federal authority
that makes sense they have in the past
always communicated with governors
i wouldn't put it past this
administration to do it very differently
or do it in a way that they didn't have
the authority to
listen from what we're seeing happen at
the southern border and what we're
seeing happen in so many of our cities
that this administration isn't shutting
down
it's dangerous it's dangerous to america
to the people that live here
and it's going to take governors
standing up and setting down
the rules on what's really going to
happen in their states
now speaking of governors we're seeing
these scenes play out
again tonight in minnesota your
neighboring state there
your counterpart tim walls is again
uh dealing with a night of uh unrest or
you know a lot of people now think he
brought this on himself
after the way they reacted early on at
least last summer
well the people of minnesota are
suffering
and we're their neighbors and we see a
lot of them moving to south dakota
frankly to get away from that type of
leadership
you know you need to have strength make
decisive decisions that are best for
your people and you need to support your
law enforcement officers listen laura i
had did a national campaign
recruiting law enforcement officers
specifically to the state of south
dakota
because i want them to know that in our
state they'll be respected
that we want them here to make their
homes here and to raise their families
here we recruited
hundreds of law enforcement officers
from 41 different states
and i'm going to launch that campaign
again we're seeing so many law
enforcement officers discouraged they've
spent their life in public service
and we want them to know that there are
people in this country that value them
and governor walsh endorsed a package
of of these really radical police
so-called reforms
last summer and it seems like this is
the result
and we have this officer charge for you
know she's been charged with uh
second degree manslaughter uh you know
we still don't know
much more about her except that she was
charged with manslaughter for 20
26-year veteran of the force but what's
been solved by this community policing
instinct i don't know what community
policing looks like to everybody either
what that definition really is i think
one of the saddest things i saw laura
was when that man lost his position for
just
saying that there is such a thing as due
process
that's what we have to make sure that we
are protecting
in this country is people's ability to
have due process
and we need to make sure that people who
speak the truth
and stand for it are defended not
removed from their positions
um you know it's well right governor
walls is enduring
yeah go ahead what governor walls is
doing in minnesota
is tragic it's harmful to his state and
to his people
and um i i think that a lot of us need
to call out the fact that leadership has
consequences and we're seeing it play
out on the streets of minneapolis
tonight
yeah well red state america has tried to
lead on a whole bunch of issues
and we see things playing out in
california
in washington state on the streets of
new york city
and baltimore the crime is is out of
control and
uh governor do you you do you see this
trend continuing where crime is going to
continue to get worse
really quickly it will get worse unless
they change their actions absolutely
uh governor thank you so much good to
see you tonight